Airbag wo hat sie gestern Abend dieses
Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts aus
Karlsruhe erreicht ich hatte gerade
sowas ähnlich sie Feierabend gemacht
okay das heißt wir waren zu Hause zu
Hause und dachte so jetzt kannst du noch
Dinge tun die nicht politisch sind ja
und dann kommt jetzt das Handy und dann
wurde noch ein bisschen telefoniert am
Abend aber wer hat sie informiert wer
hat sie angerufen das ging über
Verteiler den wir so haben dass
irgendjemand reingestellt
ich war überrascht dass es so spät am
Abend kommt ich dachte eigentlich ist
passiert über den Tag also das war ja
angekündigt dass ähm
das haben wir Mittwoch haben am Mittwoch
das Urteil kommen sollte naja und ich
dachte so ein Gericht die treffen sich
die trinken noch einen Kaffee und dann
kommt das um 10 Uhr oder 11 aber kam
halt nicht und insofern war das
Zeitpunkt überraschend ich glaube für
alle es ist sie haben nicht mehr damit
gerechnet an dem Tag habe ich nicht mehr
damit gerechnet nee und prinzipiell
damit gerechnet
naja man sagt ja immer vorgesehen also
da aber da habe ich auch einen gewissen
Sinne ist jetzt nicht
was hat den den Ablauf gestört ich hätte
mich gefreut wenn das Gesetz jetzt wo
wir uns geeinigt haben wo es aufgesetzt
ist wo alle Fraktionen
regierungstragenden Fraktion ist
beschlossen haben dann auch formal
abgeschlossen wird dass wir natürlich
auch gut gewesen nach den vielen Wochen
und Monaten der Debatte aber es ist eben
auch formal geeinigt es ist inhaltlich
beschlossen es gibt ja auch heute gar
keine Debatte mehr über die Inhalte des
Gesetzes sondern nur noch über diese
Form dann hat das Gericht halt so
entschieden dass die
Opposition mehr Zeit haben soll sich mit
dem Gesetz zu beschäftigen das ist okay
das ähm ist ich habe da Honig Respekt
vor den Urteilen aus Karlsruhe so und
jetzt machen wir das eben dann im
September nach den Sommerferien können
die Begründung dass man sagt das ich
meine was heißt kann das nachvollziehen
wie ich bin ja natürlich soll die
Opposition viel Zeit haben ausreichend
Zeit die Meinung der regierungstragenden
Fraktion der Regierung
bekanntermaßen ist das ist ungefähr dann
eine Woche im Umlauf gewesen das ist
dann auch schon ausreichende Zeit weil
es einen einen ja tief durchdiskutiertes
Gesetz war aber okay wenn mehr Zeit
gewünscht und erforderlich ist weil das
Gericht ist fest liegt dann ist es eben
so dass jetzt auch kein Beinbruch was
ist das für sie eine Niederlage oder wie
sehen Sie nein das ist gar nicht das hat
erstmal mit dem Gesetz nichts zu tun das
ist ähm eine Verfahrensfrage im
Deutschen Bundestag und die ist jetzt so
entschieden worden mit großen Respekt
vor dem Gericht sage ich okay ist halt
so entschieden worden trotzdem
entscheidend ist dass heute über den Tag
keine Fraktion auch die FDP nicht davon
abgerückt ist alle haben noch mal gesagt
das ist jetzt gut wir haben das
entschieden es wird zu beschlossen das
hat der Fraktionsvorsitzende Christian
Dörr gesagt das haben die Fachpolitiker
gesagt also insofern
ist das jetzt so und ich freue mich für
die Union dass sie jetzt Zeit hat das
Gesetz noch mal ausgiebig zu studieren
ist das nicht irre dass sie dass sie
gerade so betonen müssen dass auch die
FDP das gut findet ich meine sie ihre
eigene Regierung ja ich weiß worauf sie
anspielen aber auch in der Anmoderation
sagten sie dass das Gesetz in den
letzten Tagen oder letzten Wochen so
Schlagzeilen gesorgt hat da würde ich
ein bisschen anders drauf schauen in den
letzten Tagen und Wochen sind wir gut
zusammengekommen es hat natürlich eine
Menge
Ärger und Debatte und Aufregung
verursacht aber in den letzten Wochen
also ich habe jetzt nicht nachgezählt
aber in den letzten vier ist es deutlich
konstruktiver und ruhiger geworden zwei
Wochen saß hier Frank Schäffler von der
FDP ja und dann ausgeteilt jetzt meldet
sich Wolfgang Kubicki und sagt das ist
die verdiente Quittung
für die Tatsache dass man das so schnell
durchs Parlament Boxen wollte gut also
dass wir uns ähm in der Darstellung der
Koalition nicht immer mit rumgekleckern
und es ist immer Leute gibt die
also höflich gesprochen gegen den
strichbürsten das ist so das ist aber
nicht gut das würde ich auch
ausdrücklich sagen aber relevant ist ja
für mich was die Fraktionsvorsitzenden
und die Fachpolitiker sagen und die
haben das nicht gesagt und die Misstöne
Häme Nachtreten soll unser Stil nicht
länger sein also was ich sagen will ist
das ist ja
zugegeben dass es ein Gesetz ist das
tief in den Alltag der deutschen
eingegriffen hat oder wird
wir haben aber vor vier oder fünf Wochen
habe ich selber gesagt okay wir treten
noch mal zurück wir machen es anders wir
kombinieren es mit der kommunalen
wärmeplanung wir setzen noch mal neu ein
und vieles von dem was ich damals
vorgeschlagen habe ist dann ja auch dann
gekommen und das ist das Gesetz im Kern
wie es gedacht ist und hat noch mal
einen anderen Zugang gefunden und jetzt
ich will nicht sagen höre ich nur noch
Lob aber doch sehr viele zufriedene
stimmen damit sie können nicht zufrieden
sein mit der Art teilweise wie das
gelaufen ist und das ist das ist und Sie
können nicht zufrieden sein mit der Art
und Weise wie das vor allen Dingen mit
ihnen nach Hause gegangen ist ein
letzteres ist nicht das ist bei der
Berufswahl würde ich sagen das ist so
wenn man dafür die Verantwortung trägt
dann muss man da sitzt und sagt das
haben wir doch besprochen das steht im
Koalitionsvertrag alle wollten wir das
gemeinsam dann haben es noch mal ein
koalitionsausschüssen besprochen alle
wollten wir das gemeinsam und dass ich
plötzlich abzeichnet wird eng und da
gibt es viel Unmut da draußen waren sie
plötzlich sehr allein auf weiter Flur
ja aber das hat auch ein bisschen
getäuscht weil natürlich in Kabinett
immer wieder auch Gemeinsamkeiten da war
klar geil Witz die das Gesetz der mit
mir zusammen geschrieben hat also
geschrieben haben es natürlich ganz
viele Leute aber die das aber keine
Ahnung hat gesagt nö das würde ich nicht
sagen der Bundeskanzler klar geil wird
sie haben schon immer wieder gesagt dass
es unser Gesetz auch wir wollen dass ich
jetzt so kommt ich habe mich da ich habe
mich alleine gefühlt gar nicht aber was
entscheidender ist ist
glaube ich nicht
aber
vor allem nicht wichtig das war nicht
wichtig das Gesetz von Frau geil willst
das war nicht das heizgesetz der
Heizkammer von Olaf Scholz das war hier
halt Hammer das glaube ich nicht und ich
weiß
eine kurze Anmerkung ich weiß wie
wichtig gerade der Grünen Partei
das Bild in der Öffentlichkeit ist wie
sehr sie versuchen das Bild ihrer
entscheidenden Leute in der
Öffentlichkeit zu kontrollieren ich
erlebe das von keiner anderen Partei so
sehr wie von den Grünen dass man sehr
sehr darauf bedacht ist
das machen Leute für Sie im Hintergrund
und wir kriegen das sehr genau mit was
heißt das kann ich nicht egal gewesen
sein zu sehen wie sie von einem der
beliebtesten Politiker des Landes
Abrutschen nach ganz unten durchgereicht
werden sagen aber wie wollten das doch
alle und Sie müssen die ganze Zeit so
tun als wäre nichts ja aber also egal
ist es natürlich nicht dass wir ja
albern niemand wünscht sich der
Politiker ist
irgendwie unbeliebt zu sein oder seine
Partei im Umfrage Tiefen zu führen aber
es ist wiederum nicht das zentrale
gewesen die ganze Zeit weil das nicht
dass das normale persönlich auch
manchmal naja man muss ein bisschen
aufpassen dass man nicht verhärtet weil
ja dieses ähm diese Geräuschkulisse das
ist alles sehr laut wenn ich so in einem
Bild bleiben darf und wenn alles sehr
laut ist dann hört man manchmal nicht
mehr genau zu und das ist sicherlich
auch passiert dass man unter dem Druck
oder unter dem Vorwürfen oder ich sage
nicht mal von mir unter dem Drücken
nicht mehr
Nebentöne berechtigte Kritik
intensiv genug wahrgenommen hat stimmt
es dass eben auch viel unberechtigte
Kritik war aber das ist ja würde ich
sagen gerade noch rechtzeitig gelungen
dann doch zu sagen so jetzt jetzt hören
wir mal durch die Lautstärke durch was
ist jetzt eigentlich der Kern und dann
verändern wir es noch einmal dann noch
einmal das sagen darf ja die ich weiß
nicht ob ich das hier bei ihnen gesagt
habe es kommt mir fast zu vor jedenfalls
habe ich mal gesagt und das ist auch
meine feste Überzeugung
wenn man in dieser Zeit die ja in
mehrfacher Hinsicht turbulent ist nervös
einen machen kann viele Krisen die
Kriege die Ukraine
viel beansprucht und eben auch erfordert
viele Entscheidungen schnell und auch
mit einer gewissen Härte zu treffen wenn
man dann jetzt Regierungsmitglied ist
oder Politikerin Politiker ist um
beliebt zu sein sondern gleich zu Hause
bleiben das ist natürlich nicht das Ziel
unbeliebt zu sein das muss man aber
Trennen von der Sucht populär zu sein
das habe ich mir festgeschworen dass
dieses Amt und die Verantwortung damit
nicht Mittel zum Zweck für irgendwas
weiteres ist sondern in sich selber
seine Begründung hat deswegen habe ich
nie daran gezweifelt dass es richtig ist
okay so eingesetzt zu machen wie ist
genau aussieht das war ja immer
diskutabel und das haben wir nun auch
geändert aber das dass man bereit ist
seine Popularität auf Spiel zu setzen
das ist die Eintrittsbedingungen für
jeden der im Moment auf der politischen
Bühne unterwegs ist
stimmt es dass sie teilweise Bürger
BürgerInnen selber angerufen haben die
besonders wütende empörte Briefe
geschrieben ja letztere stimmt nicht
ganz also es gab ja Unmengen von Mails
und Briefen die teilweise auch nicht
eine einen eine Hilfe Ruf oder eine
echte Frage beinhaltet sondern nur
Beschimpfung die habe ich dann nicht
angerufen und ich habe nicht so viel
angerufen wie ich mir eigentlich
vorgenommen habe aber ich habe das
gemacht ja ich habe Leute angerufen und
gesagt sie haben mir geschrieben jetzt
versuche ich das mal zu erklären und das
war toll wen haben Sie angerufen ja
irgendwelche Leute ich könnte dir ja
nicht aber das war toll das waren die
waren erfreut und ähm das waren jetzt ja
keine Liebesbriefe sondern die hatten
also ja berechtigt laute Kritik aber
sobald wir gesprochen haben was
was gut war auch für mich gut weil die
mir dann ja sehr konkret aus dem Alltag
heraus geschildert haben warum sie
meinen das bestimmte Sachen nicht gehen
oder bestimmte Informationen nicht
angekommen sind ja also ich hätte mir
gewünscht ich hätte mehr Zeit dafür
gehabt das öfter zu machen aber hin und
wieder oder ein paar Mal habe ich es
machen können interessant dafür darf ich
noch mal fragen haben sie das Land
überfordert ich habe selber auch also
noch nie so häufig gehört auch von
Menschen Ärzte Ärztinnen zum Beispiel
Kinder der HNO-Ärztin sehr taffe Frau
die unglaublich viel arbeitet die sich
wahnsinnig anstrengend sie sagt pass auf
das kann ich mir nicht leisten
funktioniert nicht und sie sagt ich bin
nicht Friedrich Merz obere Mittelschicht
aber so mittlere Mittelschicht da da bin
ich zu Hause und wir sitzen zusammen
beim Grillen und überlegen und ich
glaube so geht's gerade ganz ganz viel
die sitzen zusammen und überlegen wie
soll ich das machen auch Leute
bei denen an Bewusstsein da ist dass wir
ein Problem haben das kürzlich der
heißeste Tag war global gesehen der
jemals in der Geschichte der Menschheit
gemessen worden ist also die merken dass
da draußen was passiert aber auch die
sagen tut mir leid da komme ich nicht
mit auch ich als gut verdienen der
Ärztin haben sie das falsch angefasst
also das ist der eine soziale
Problematik gegeben hat oder gibt nun
haben wir die Fördersätze noch einmal
deutlich erhöht das ist ja
offensichtlich aber es war auch vieles
im Umlauf was nicht richtig ist
technisch nicht richtig ist und das
Gesetz auch nie gefordert hat also das
begann ja damit das ist jetzt müssen wir
alle unsere Heizung ausbauen es war eine
Heizung haben also ein heizverbot für
die Quatsch natürlich sollte geheizt
werden und es ging auch nie darum
laufende Heizung also intakte heile
Heizung rauszubauen ist immer nur darum
wenn die Dinger mal kaputt gehen dann
bauen wir nicht grenzenlos Weiterbildung
Gasheizung ein wir müssen ja mal
irgendwann unseren eigenen Beschlüssen
auch einen Wert zu kommen lassen dafür
gab es immer Übergangsfristen es gab
immer Härtefall Regeln es gab immer
großzügige Unterstützung also da wohnst
nicht gegangen wäre dann hätte man halt
ein anderes ein anderes System nehmen
können das war nie
nie wie soll ich dann aus wie Kloß nur
die eine Lösung und so weiter aber das
ist vielleicht gar nicht der
entscheidende Punkt sondern der
entscheidende Punkt ist das habe ich an
anderer Stelle auch gesagt dass dieses
Gesetz zwei Gründe hatte der erste war
Klimaschutz so hat sich die Koalition
als wir in die Regierung gegangen sind
September darauf geeinigt dass wir zu
einem Gesetz machen das zu 25 wirksam
werden soll und der zweite Grund war die
Gaskrise die im letzten Jahr drohte das
hat dazu geführt dass wir das Gesetz
vorgezogen haben und das Erinnern Sie
sicherlich noch was wir alles für
verrückte Dinge gemacht haben wir haben
unsere Innenstädte teilweise dunkel
gehabt die Gebäude nicht mehr
angestrahlt die öffentlichen Gebäude
wurden auf 19 Grad
der runtergefahren nicht sie wollen ja
hochgefahren wer draußen Kälte aber aber
das war die Durchschnittstemperatur also
in meinem Ministerium hatten wir auch
Räume wo Leute wirklich gefroren haben
weil man das dann nicht mehr
ausbalancieren konnte und es einfach
viel zu kalt war dafür und
Leute haben freiwillig enorme
Energiemengen eingespart und so weiter
wir haben uns da ja wir haben uns ja
auch was zugemutet und sehr viele
Unternehmen hat ein sehr konkrete Angst
dass es eine gasmangelage gibt dass sie
abgeschaltet werden das war alles real
und von diesem Hintergrund das war
sozusagen die die die die Aufgabe auch
die zu diesem schnellen Gesetz geführt
hat schien jede weitere eingebaute
Gasheizung das Problem zu vergrößern so
deswegen das ist eingestanden ist das
ist das Gesetz sehr schnell und auch in
dem Sinne radikal gewesen und gesagt
dann würden wir damit jetzt auch aus
dieser ja das ist ja unstrittig radikal
genau das ist ein gutes Wort dafür ja
das ist aber auch das ist so das ist
zuzugeben
kommend aus dem was hätte passieren
können in 22 Winter 23
angemessen ich habe gerade aufgezählt
was ich gesagt habe jedenfalls schien es
mir angemessen und dann ist zwischen dem
Ende des Winters der
kurz war und dem Frühling etwas passiert
nämlich diese Bedrohungslage ist nicht
mehr als dominant wahrgenommen worden
sie ist doch immer da wenn ich das sagen
darf ja haben wir haben das im Griff
aber wir haben es nicht überwunden aber
es wurde nicht mehr als als
Hauptbegründung für dieses Gesetz
wahrgenommen und das ist sozusagen
da fehlte mir der Moment des Innehaltens
aus dem Lauf raus dieses Land vor einer
gasmangelage zu beschützen zu sagen ach
guck mal da ist ja gerade die Begründung
weggefallen das kannst du mir mal einen
Meter zurücktreten alles betrachten
Interesse daran gehen andere Fristen so
das ist dann das ist dann sozusagen
meine Erklärung wie wie diese Diskussion
so entgleiten konnte habe ich zwei
Fragen dazu Gesetze zu machen Dinge zu
verändern ist ist ja auch eine Frage des
Timings
also wäre es vielleicht sogar besser
gewesen diese dramatische Situation in
gewisser Weise zu nutzen und zu sagen
jetzt machen wir das gleich mit also kam
das Gesetz quasi ja es wäre
wahrscheinlich gedacht ja darüber habe
ich nachgedacht es wäre nicht möglich
gewesen weil wir die Kapazitäten nicht
mehr hatten so ein Gesetz zu schreiben
und das muss in der begleitet werden und
Leute werden beteiligt und so weiter
also das wäre nicht aber nein die
rückblickend habe ich gesagt was wäre
wohl gewesen wenn das im
September 22 22 passiert wäre
wahrscheinlich wäre es anders gewesen
aber
erstens ist eine sinnlose Frage und
zweitens wäre es dann ja jetzt nicht
minder radikal gewesen möglicherweise
hätten wir dann ein beschlossenes Gesetz
aber die gleiche Debatte jetzt und so
was ich also sagen will ist das waren
unruhige Zeiten die haben vielen vielen
Dank und jetzt haben Sie ein gutes Ende
gefunden und das Ende
müssen wir noch ein bisschen warten das
hat ein gutes Ende gefunden und das ist
auch ein qualitativ gutes Gesetz jetzt
und äh deswegen können wir uns mit den
nächsten Aufgaben befassen darüber reden
wir auch gleich noch mal nur noch mal
das Wasser sozusagen kulturell passiert
wir hatten einigen Tagen ist schon ein
paar Wochen her Winfried Kretschmann
hier zu Besuch
ihn natürlich bestens bekannt der hat
sie immer noch öffentlich kritisiert
aber der schätzt sie auf der anderen
Seite sehr das ist jemand der der sagt
Robert habe ist einer der der stellt
sich im Wind der traut sich was aber so
wie das gemacht war war das katastrophal
falsch wir hören einmal kurz rein in
seine Begründung sehr interessant bitte
schön
ergreifen bei allem respektischen
außerordentlich kluger klugerkopf
gewesen woher kommt der der kommt aus
dem singtank nicht da denkt man
konzeptionell genau Papier solche Leute
sind ganz wichtig um dir zu raten aber
die denken natürlich immer top-down man
kann nicht eine Gesellschaft von oben
nach unten durch regieren und denken und
dann sind sie noch staatsgläubig bis in
die Knochen das hat keinen Sinn ich du
du musst von oben nach unten denken du
brauchst Konzert da muss immer auch von
unten nach oben denkt das so gegen Strom
Prinzip nur so kann man erfolgreich
etwas hinbekommen
hat er recht natürlich müssen wir uns
nicht von beiden Seiten den annähern
kein Konzert zu haben also nicht wissen
wohin man will keine kein Plan zu haben
ist ziemlich schlecht aber natürlich zu
sagen ich habe einen Plan und den müsst
ihr jetzt fressen egal was passiert ist
natürlich auch schlecht radikal meinten
noch einmal wir hatten eine radikale
Situation also dass das Gebäude
Energiegesetz ja auf die Krise des und
die drohende Krise des Jahres 22 23
wo ja weiter Gasheizung eingebaut wurden
wir haben im also als der Gaspreis am
höchsten war und auch keine Aussicht auf
Besserung da war als wir wirklich
befürchten mussten
hier wird es kann es eine schwere
Wirtschaftskrise geben wurden 600.000
neue Heizung eingekauft dazu sagen wenn
wir hier nicht und das war im Winter
nicht absehbar wie sie wie entspannt die
Situation früher ist
ich will das nicht noch mal teilweise
mir ist schon klar dass das viel Ärger
gegeben hat und viele Menschen sich
Ärger dann saniert gefühlt haben und so
weiter ich will es nicht entschuldigen
das will ich will es nur erklären es ist
aus der es hatte den Aspekt Klimaschutz
und dann ist es vorgezogen worden ist
hat einen anderen Aspekt und der war
dann nicht mehr da so und und noch mal
fragen wie weit wie weit denkt man
lieber so etwas nach man dann sitzt man
im Ministerium er sagt gerade das ist
dieser Staatssekretär Herr greifen denn
exzellenter Mann ist wer sagt aber ein
Mann der Papiere die reinen die reine
leere sozusagen und dann wird top down
wie es ausdrückt einfach von oben
angesagt und das ist ich habe dieser
Tage mit einem Politikwissenschaftler
gesprochen der sagte denken Sie mal
darüber nach das ist das Kernproblem
dieser grünen Partei nämlich diese Idee
wir müssen Euch von oben was Ansagen
wenn man es verhetzen will sagt man
verbieten und immer weiter verbieten
weil ihr da unten zu doof seid zu
verstehen was gut für euch ist ja das
hatte aber eigentlich steht das
natürlich meiner Meinung ja umgekehrt
sage ich was das kein Problem auch ist
auch ein bisschen jetzt als
Wirtschaftsminister gesprochen dieses
Landes kein Konzept zu haben
und das holt uns jetzt gerade bitte ein
ich will nicht ablenken wir können noch
gerne weiter über das Gebäude
sprechende Beispiele ja wir haben eine
klaffende Arbeits- und Fachkräfte Lücke
im Moment weil wir älter werden UPS wir
werden älter das kann ja wohl keinem vor
entgangen sein dass wir älter werden und
das mehr Leute aus dem Arbeitsmarkt
ausschalten als reinkommen und wir sind
ja noch an einer Stagnationsphase die
Wirtschaft hat nicht voll angezogen die
zieht unter anderem nicht so schnell von
uns Arbeitskräfte fehlen das hat man
gesehen alle wussten das und wir haben
getan nichts ich kann andere Beispiele
nennen halb Europa hat Smart Mieter also
intelligente Stromzähler die auf
schwankende Strompreise Signale in die
Haushalte oder in die Unternehmen geben
und sagen jetzt macht es Sinn weil es
günstig ist Strom zu verbrauchen und
später wenn man wegen im Sommer wenn die
Sonne untergegangen ist ist teurer wird
weil die Solarenergie fehlt jetzt macht
es vielleicht wenig lange sind halb
Europa nutzt diese Dinge Deutschland
nicht warum weil wir uns nicht gekümmert
haben das brauchen wir aber für das
Energiesystem auch um Verbraucher und
Verbraucher zu ändern ich könnte Ihnen
meterweise Probleme aufzählen die
eigentlich unerklärlich sind warum sind
sie da weil sich die Politik nicht darum
gekümmert hat und deswegen ja ich weiß
was sie sagen die Grünen und haben einen
Plan und den wollen sie durchsetzen aber
kein Plan zu haben scheint mehr fasst
das größere Problem zu sein und wir
leiden bitterlich darunter dass das
einfach alles ausgesessen wurde wir
haben ja geglaubt nur weil wir
beschlossen haben wir werden
klimaneutral sind hier ist also die
große Koalition und mit Verlaub das Land
hat geglaubt wir sind die Klimaschutz
Weltmeister und in Wahrheit waren wir in
allen Bereichen zu schlecht jetzt werden
die Dinge konkret das ist unangenehm
konkret heißt sie werden sichtbar sie
werden persönlich die Rücken einen nahe
das bedeutet guten notwendigerweise
Debatte ist bedeutet notwendigerweise
Streit aber jetzt muss man sich dann
auch entscheiden als Politiker selbst
oder auch als Wählerinnen und Wähler als
Bürger oder dieses landesbürgerinnen und
Bürger dieses Landes will man es bequem
haben und eine Politik die sich nicht um
die Probleme kümmert oder die versucht
die Probleme zu lösen und auch wenn es
Streit bedeutet Streit muss ja nicht
heißen dass wir uns so zerlegen wie es
jetzt die letzten Monate war aber ich
glaube man sollte zu Hause bleiben wenn
man nicht bereit ist letzteres zu tun
okay ich ich ich höre sehr aufmerksam zu
und ich bin mir auch sicher dass es
nicht so gemeint ist aber dieses Wort
bequem in dem Zusammenhang stößt mir
gerade sehr
aufgesetzt oder insgesamt
gedanklich danke
leisten können schlecht unter greifen
die die stehen dann sagen wie soll ich
das jetzt machen
eine Förderung von für die Einkommen bis
40 bis 40.000 von 70 Prozent ich weiß
mir geht es um den Punkt des Anfangs
warum also diese diese Kultur sozusagen
dieses
patriarchalische auch das ist ja etwas
was in vielen Gesellschaften dieser Welt
gerade den Leuten unfassbar aufstößt das
hat unter anderem auch zum Erfolg von
Donald Trump geführt das hat zum brexit
geführt das hat so rechtspopulistischen
rechtsnationalen Regierungen innerhalb
Europa geführt dieses Gefühl der Leute
da gibt es so dieses paternalistische
von oben herab wir streicheln euch so
einmal über den Kopf und dann macht ihr
bitte was wir euch sagen ich verstehe
nicht warum man das so machen muss ich
ich denke manchmal wäre es nicht
schlauer zu fördern kein Gesetz
schreiben nein das meine ich nicht oder
ich meine das Gegenteil davon ich ich
will ein Beispiel machen die Amerikaner
zum Beispiel Joe Biden
die Amerikaner würden im Traum nicht auf
die Idee kommen eine Jahreszahl zu
nennen für das Ende eines Verbrenners im
Leben nicht was machen die nicht
der Gedanke zu Ende sie setzen Anreize
sie sagen pass auf wir wir fördern das
macht doch mit Nadine nennen die das ja
die Leute so ein bisschen dahin stupsen
und sagen mach doch mal anderes schönes
Beispiel
die Steuerbehörde
die Tritte nicht sofort trampelig auf
die Füße und sagt pass auf deine
Steuererklärung hast du mich eingereicht
sondern die schreiben dich an und sagen
pass auf dein Nachbar Joe der hat seine
Steuererklärung schon abgegeben willst
du auch so dieses ein bisschen
dahintreiben drittes Beispiel in den USA
gibt es keinen CO2-Preis das heißt
Benzin Gas all die Dinge werden nicht
permanent teurer und bringen die Leute
sozusagen von beiden Seiten dass er das
was bei uns passiert deswegen kommt auch
diese verzweifelte Situation irgendwann
du stehst da und sagst okay soll ich
jetzt diese Gasheizung noch kaufen aber
irgendwann sagt er ja jemand CO2-Preis
das wird also immer teurer dann soll ich
mir auf der anderen Seite die Wärmepumpe
kaufen aber kann ich mir jetzt nicht
leisten ist zu viel Geld und auch zu
viel Verunsicherung im Markt ich
verstehe nicht warum wir die Leute statt
ihnen ständig etwas vorzuschreiben und
sie zu Gängen und einfach sagen pass auf
mach doch hier ist der Anreiz mach doch
einfach mit das ist in meinen Augen der
wird Fehler der Geschichte
jetzt haben sie sehr viele Beispiele
genannt und ich weiß gar nicht ob ich
das alles noch auseinander kleinwiedern
kann aber wenn ich dabei ist auch sehr
viel keine Frage sondern these und
Unterstellungen wenn ich das einmal ganz
allgemein ihr könnt gleich wieder über
Klimaschutz reden aber wenn ich an
bestimmte Bereiche der amerikanischen
Gesellschaft denke würde ich mir würde
ich denken ein paar mehr Regeln werden
so falsch nicht Waffenkontrolle oder so
etwas zu sagen nudging scheint mir da
jetzt irgendwie auch nicht die klügste
aller Lösung zu sein
der CO2-Preis ist immer als
Gegenargument gegen das Gesetz genannt
worden also das ist ja
solange der FDP gewesen wir machen kein
Gesetz wir machen einen CO2-Preis der
dann wenn er die gleiche Wirkung hätte
haben sollen sehr sehr hoch sein müssen
das hätte das hätte erst recht auch die
Ärzte gesprochen haben ist gerade
geschrieben da kommt diese
Verunsicherung rein du weißt Förderung
haben sie aufgezählt die die Amerikaner
fördern das tun wir auch und zwar bis 70
% jetzt 70 % für Einkommen bis 40.000 €
im Monat und danach baut er sich dann
oder setzt sich anders zusammen aber
auch dann kann man noch bis 50% bekommen
die hatten wir auch bei dem alten Gesetz
vorgesehen in der Tat diese soziale
Staffelung die wir damals auf der
Regierungsseite nicht mehr möglich
gewesen aber 50% Förderung gab es davor
auch und
bleibt halt am Ende die große Frage
kommen wir ohne Gesetze nur aufgrund von
gesellschaftlicher Verabredung durch
und ich nehme ein anderes Beispiel ich
glaube nicht ja ich glaube dass das
Gesetze ich verstehe was sie sagen
erlernt ich weiß dass das es gibt nur
den Punkt sozusagen traut man den Leuten
etwas zu oder traut man ihn nicht zu den
Leuten ganz viel zu
Sie persönlich
bestimmte politische Kultur das meine
Lehre wenn man jemanden der Herren
reichen zum Beispiel auch sieht und hört
niemand hat die Leine leger vertreten
auch Patrick reichen nicht wenn ich das
sagen darf aber wir ich nehme andere
Beispiele um es ein bisschen zu öffnen
um die Klimaneutralität herzustellen
brauchen wir viel erneuerbare energielie
erneuerbaren Strom auf auf der See also
offshore und schon und Solar aber wir
haben gesehen dass der Ausbau
zusammengebrochen ist wir haben dann
einen Gesetz gemacht ein Gesetz gemacht
dass alle Bundesländer verpflichtet um
zwei Prozent ihrer Landesfläche für Wind
Energie bis 2032 zur Verfügung zu
stellen ein Gesetz gemacht natürlich
hätte man auch sagen können und sehr
lange wurde das auch gesagt müssen wir
noch gar nicht machen ist leuchtet doch
ein wenn wir das machen wollen dann
müssen alle sich daran beteiligen und
wenn die Energie günstiger ist dann
macht es auch Sinn die bei euch vor Ort
zu haben weil dann die Industrie direkt
sich dann Kabel legen kann und dann hat
sie halt Windstrom und das machen auch
ganz viele Unternehmen ist ein Standort
Vorteil geworden inzwischen hat aber
niemand getan ja den sie erkennen ich
habe gesehen der war auch mal hier bei
Ihnen vor kurzer Zeit war diese Woche ja
also in Bayern ist nichts passiert und
jetzt passiert weil es ein Gesetz gibt
und das Gesetz sorgt dafür dass die
Leute sagen wann passiert es denn wann
kriege ich denn meine Windkraftanlage
und natürlich heißt das Gesetz nicht
wann wo exakt was passiert das müssen
schon die Menschen vor Ort machen das
kann eine Bundesregierung auch gar nicht
aber der Sinn von Gesetzen und ich rede
sehr allgemein ja ich streite nicht ab
das ist enorme Schwierigkeiten Probleme
Zumutung beim Gebäude Energiegesetz
gegeben hat wenn ich schon in der
Vergangenheit reden darf aber der Sinn
von Gesetzen ist eben auch
eine dass die Politik in die
Verantwortung trägt tritt und die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die Kommunen
vielleicht auch die Landespolitik von
den Dingen entlastet die man sich sonst
nicht zumuten will und die Sicherheit
die da entstanden ist die ist ja
gigantisch wieder zurück zum Heizen zum
Gebäude Energiegesetz ich meine allein
der Immobilienmarkt beispielsweise was
da passiert ist kriegt das auch so mit
Menschen kaufen keine Immobilien mehr
weil sie nicht wissen was kaufe ich mir
noch einen kauf ich mir eine sehr teure
Sanierung in Zukunft ein Menschen
kriegen also keine Immobilien verkauft
wenn sie es möglicherweise Vorhaben weil
sie vielleicht den Rente gehen weil die
Immobilie die Absicherung fürs Alter war
und ähnliche Dinge also das hat ihn ganz
ganz viele Bereiche des Lebens hinein
unglaubliche Konsequenzen das ist der
Punkt ein Drittel der ein Drittel der
Energie die wir in Deutschland
verbrauchen da brauchen wir heizen
meistens Fossil
oder andere Länder haben das schon
früher angefangen und sind da viel
besser und weiter aber egal ein Drittel
natürlich es ist ja unstrittig und das
erklärt es ja auch auf der allgemeinsten
Ebene ist ein Gesetz das ein Drittel des
Energieverbrauchs in Deutschland
adressiert unglaublich wirksam und
greift ganz tief in das Leben und in die
in die verschiedenen Prozesse ein
deswegen ist es ja ist es ja so
umstritten gewesen das ist das ist aber
das war erwartet das war mir klar
wahrscheinlich sagen gab es das davor in
der Form nicht wenn man sich also man
keine Lust hatte oder Angst hatte es zu
schreiben weil man sich nicht mit Leuten
anlegen will weil die Anläufe die davor
da waren also ein Ministerium arbeitet
ja so dass die Experten die da sind
auch gucken was du in Europa los ist was
andere Länder machen und und dann gehen
die zu den Ministern und sagen da gibt
es eine kluge die da können wir das
nicht auch machen das gab es hier auch
schon also es gab schon viele Anläufe so
was zu tun aber es ist immer politisch
eingesammelt worden und gesagt hat bloß
nicht bloß nicht macht mich unpopulär da
und stattdessen haben wir angefangen
Gasheizung zu fördern also wir haben ja
wir haben ja nicht nur nichts getan in
dem Bereich oder zu wenig sondern wir
haben auch noch das Gegenteil getan wir
haben die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
ermutigt finanziell unterstützt fossile
Gasheizung einzubauen das heißt wir
haben Steuergeld wahrscheinlich Schulden
finanzierte Steuergeld genommen um
fossile Gasheizung günstiger zu machen
das ungefähr das Gegenteil von dem was
eigentlich notwendig gewesen wäre also
ich will damit sagen ja Gesetze wenn Sie
so wollen sind Bevormundung
das gilt für alle Gesetze da würde ich
aber mal sagen wünschen sich eine Welt
ohne Gesetze das ist glaube ich nicht
klug aber das hat natürlich
z.B hören
wenn wir demnächst wieder regieren ja
Markus Söder hat seine Meinung schon so
schnell wieder geändert das
was ich dazu sagen
Markus Söder ist nicht die CDU sehr
viele die CDU sagt das auch Jens Spahn
zum Beispiel saß auch hier ist auch
nicht die CDU sehr viele Kollegen aus
den Ländern die teilweise mit den Grünen
Regierungen sind denke ich haben jetzt
ihr Frieden mit dem Gesetz gemacht
haben schon lange wärmepläne
verpflichtend in den Bundesländern
vorgesehen Schleswig-Holstein
Baden-Württemberg Nordrhein-Westfalen
alles CDU mitgeführte Länder haben links
auf den Weg gemacht
und ich habe jetzt muss ich hier heute
Abend lieber Markus wieder reden
müssen Sie nicht
stattdessen wenn ich muss aber groß Lust
habe ich auch nicht der hat sie zum
neuen Feind erklärt also nicht Sie
persönlich aber die Grünen ja das ist ja
nicht mein Problem das muss ja mit sich
selbst in seiner Parteien
ich glaube wenn ich das richtig weiß um
ihn ein bisschen zu schützen hat er
gesagt Feind ist die AFD die Grünen sind
der Gegner der Hauptgegner ja oder sowas
noch korrekt formulieren
genau
Schwäche gesprochen sein weil er wohl
vergessen hat dass seine Partei in der
Hälfte der Bundesländer mit den Grünen
regiert kann ja nicht richtig sein dass
seine Ministerpräsidenten mit dem
Hauptgegner regieren da hat er glaube
ich richtig nachgedacht und ich denke
das ist ihm klar